do you guys think dog owners really look
like their dogs we're now random
contestants try to match these dog
owners to their dogs and we'll find out
dog owners could you please give me your
leashes Lord Zack do you think people
are going to know the Franklin sir dog I
think so because we're both pretty big
dogs and I think people could put two
and two together like that for both
blonde and very high-energy
I think you could tell he is my dog
because we both have droopy red eyes and
resting that is if you just look at me
you wouldn't think that I would have a
dog this small and cute I have some you
know light hair highlights like she does
but same hair your color I don't think
we really have the same body type Samson
do you think people are gonna know
Morgan's your human mm-hmm
so Nina do you think dogs look like
their people yeah awesome I think
sometimes yeah do you think you're gonna
be able to match these people to their
dogs based on their looks I gonna do my
best
yes handle each of the dogs the person
owns it oh my god I'm sorry
alright this one is for red fun how
about you walk with me
usually hell let's go to your daddy
so mum the faster the better for me is
it the Hat dogs hate hat racks hey Dad
yeah I guess you big you not you know I
put confidence over here Nina
good work it's on the face you go how do
you think you did horrible how many do
you think you got right uh two maybe
how confident are you that you have
these right I'm pretty confident I think
I got two right so Meghan is this your
dog it's not Samson and Zach you're
human
Samson is not my dog nor does he want to
be my dog
Franklin is not my wife oh hey over here
cuz she is so desperate to get back to
me my god
Roxie is not my dog she's my dog Megan
is Roxy your dog she's not say it's not
my dog
Franklin is not my dog but I honored
that you think that he is curious my dog
ah yeah the same here
Sampson is not my dog yeah Darwin is my
dog okay
okay you ready to find out the real
answers yeah let's go is Faye you're
done
hey is my dog Sampson is not my dog yeah
Roxy's my dog chewy is my dog
Franklin is not my god putter is not my
dog and Morgan is Darwin your dog Darwin
is unfortunately not my dog show
contestants are you ready to find out
who won yes it was Hugo
yes how many did you get right here go
ahh
how does it feel to be a champion
awesome hahaha
and how does it feel to be a loser great
I should get a dog as my consolation all
right dog owners get your real dogs oh
here you go jump into her arms me here
you go we're good I think there's some
family resemblance and hair color some I
some other connections Thanks I lose can
be deceiving but hey sometimes I let you
said yeah they look white like the
honors they don't look like their owners
folks I was do people really look like
their dogs and I would say the jury is
definitely still out what do you think